die einen hatten sich endlich
lockerungen gewünscht die anderen
endlich sicherheit enttäuscht sind sie
beide und das aus dem gleichen grund
sehr sicher öffnen will der muss
voraussetzungen schaffen beim impfen
beim testen und beim kontakt verfolgen
unter fehlt ist leider überall das
verbieten klappt in deutschland super
das ermöglichen nicht und so könnten am
ende alle kritiker recht haben die
lockerungen kommen schon zu spät und sie
kommen immer noch zu früh
wir müssen reden mit diesen gästen
manuela schwesig ministerpräsidenten von
mecklenburg vorpommern stellt fest frau
merkel und herr spahn versagen im kampf
gegen korona christian lindner
der fdp-vorsitzende findet für die
regierung bleibt offenbar der locker und
das einzig denkbare rezept dieter
hallervorden der schauspieler sagt an
dieser katastrophe ist nicht nur corona
schuld sondern auch die politik
hendrik strikt der virologe fordert wir
müssen die bereiche mit den besten
hygieneregeln öffnen
robert habeck der grünen-vorsitzende
sagt hoffentlich stecken wir an ostern
nicht im nächsten lockdown melanie amann
für die spiegel journalistin ist klar
wir priorisieren uns zu tode und markus
söder
der bayerische ministerpräsident sagt es
wären andere öffnungen möglich wäre mehr
impfstoff bestellt worden
sie sind zu gast bei maybrit illner ab
und begrüßte gestern ausgesprochen
herzlich toll dass sie mit dabei sind
egal ob im studio oder zugeschaltet und
los gehts gestern mal wieder eine
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
es sollte die wichtigste sein
herausgekommen westdeutschland will raus
durch fünf tore sollen wir gehen raus
aus dem schatten 50 die neue 35 zwei
wochen halten und weiter geht's über 50
wird's nicht so leicht über 100 kommt
die notbremse und wieder schließen
irgendwie klingt kompliziert ist
offenbar aber ganz einfach das ist ein
plan den wir haben der auf eine din a4
seite passt
schritt 1 und 2 schon durch grundschulen
auf pflanzen märkte buchläden vielerorts
genauso und das obwohl wir auch jetzt
noch zu wenig tests haben die oberste
mahnerin sie trotzdem chancen fürs
weiter lockern
der frühling 2021 wird anders sein als
der frühling vor einem jahr auf zwei
dinge richtete sich die hoffnung impfen
und testen
das große testprogramm allerdings
erstmal verschoben
die mutter bleibt auf dem vormarsch und
impfdosen fehlen bis heute im chaos
möglich was lange unmöglich schien
impfen darf auch bald der hausarzt für
massig test soll jetzt eine taskforce
sorgen geballte minister kompetenz für
schnell nachschub bei den pisten sind
wir in deutschland nicht so weit wie wir
ganz sein möchten und beim impfen ließ
einfach ganz klar das sind wir im
internationalen vergleich nicht da wo
wir sein möchten
im klartext weil viel schief läuft ist
mehr öffnen unmöglich und dringend
gebraucht wird übrigens auch eine neue
app vorsicht bleibt oberstes gebot jeder
einzelne sei in der pflicht so heißt es
wieder mal bis ostern ist vieles möglich
auch ein neuer shutdown manuela schwesig
die ministerpräsidenten von
mecklenburg-vorpommern ist und
zugeschaltet aus jährigen frau schwesig
sie sagen sparen und merkel haben in
dieser pandemie versagt warum guten
haben frau illner
also wir müssen nach vier monaten
shutter und feststellen dass der
schatten was gebracht hat das schon mal
das gute wir sind in den zahlen runter
gekommen
aber es reicht nicht und man kann jetzt
nicht einfach immer nur weiter
verlängern
wir müssen auch den menschen eine
perspektive geben und das ist was sich
viele wünschen und die perspektive ist
möglich mit neuen instrumenten das ist
zum einen das impfen ja und das ist zum
anderen das testen und beim impfen habe
ich mich ja schon beim letzten mal hier
klar geäußert für mich ist völlig
unverständlich warum die europäische
union auch unter der eu
ratspräsidentschaft zu spät und zu wenig
impfstoff bestellt hat das fällt uns
jetzt auf die füße
es stehen keine impfdosen rum sondern
wir haben zu wenig wir können deshalb
jetzt zum beispiel nicht über die
hausärzte das impfen ausrollen
wir machen das ja schon in mecklenburg
vorpommern in einem pilotprojekt es
läuft super
aber wenn sie alle hausärzte einbeziehen
wollen dann brauchen sie hat auch mehr
impfstoff und jetzt der nächste
tiefschlag beim testen haben wir sehr
auf die selbsttests gesetz die kommen ja
jetzt auch aber anstatt dass der bund
dafür gesorgt hat dass die selbsttest
erstmal die länder nutzen können zb
umfangreich für kitas
in abzusichern landen sie jetzt bei aldi
und wir gehen eine sage ich mal
komplizierte variante jetzt ab nächste
woche über apotheken testzentren ich
finde das könnte man besser organisieren
aber ich bin trotzdem froh dass wir
gestern eine perspektive eröffnet haben
viele bereiche wollen wissen wie es
weitergeht wie es weitergeht vorsichtig
muss man sicherlich bleiben weil uns
genau diese instrumente fehlen für
lockerungen robert habeck ist bei uns
einer der zwei vorsitzenden der grünen
er habe ich vorsichtig sind auch sie
sind wir nur sehr mit der mit dieser
pandemie politik tatsächlich zu träge
sind wir vorsichtig sind wir zu
vorsichtig oder glauben sie dass der
bürger sowieso nicht mehr versteht warum
wir jetzt öffnen wenn wir eigentlich in
einer sehr unsicheren lage sind also der
tag gestern glaube ich kann im nachgang
eine echte zäsur gewesen sein wir haben
ja die vorzeichen völlig verkehrt sonst
wurde bei 50 geschlossen jetzt wird bei
50 gelockert das ist quasi die umkehrung
der denkrichtung komplett und begründet
und das macht mir viel größere sorgen
offensichtlich politisch also nicht
ideologisch sondern die politiker sind
getrieben die politik ist getrieben
und ich glaube dass das nicht bitter
rächen wird können
das vertrauen in getriebene politiker
ist nicht besonders ausgeprägt deswegen
vor schwesig die kritik an der
bundesregierung sicherlich richtig aber
in der situation dann zu sagen wir
machen dann trotzdem das gegenteil von
dem bisher davor gesagt haben ist auch
nicht richtig
vielleicht kann ich das kurz erklären
naja kurz ist schwierig in krone aber
das macht sich hier habe ich ein
bisschen so einfach und die politik
hätte selber politiker mir ist nicht
bekannt dass die grünen besonders guten
vorschlag im bundestag eingebracht
hätten aber das ist egal
sondern es geht um die institute vor
drei wochen haben wir gesagt wir müssen
wegen der mutation vorsichtig sein und
gehen erstmal keine weiteren öffnung
schritte es sei denn die es gibt
regionen die unter 35 sind mittlerweile
kann man aber sagen die inzidenz können
wir neu bewerten weil es weitere
maßstäbe wie ist srk
selbst vorgeschlagen hat wir können
stärker auf die kapazitäten in den
krankenhäusern schauen
zum glück zahlt sich das impfen in den
altenheimen aus wir sind ja im land
komplett durch und sehen dass wir haben
bei den älteren dort kaum noch
erkrankungen und zum glück keine
schweren und auch keine todesfälle
darauf hatte das omnia ii auf wenn die
auf diese weise es was dazugehört ist
dass wir stärker sind wert und testen
und dann kann man schon auch bei einer
höheren instanz mehr wagen und eins ist
auch klar man kann den menschen nicht
einfach so sagen weiter so ich habe von
herrn habe ich jetzt noch nichts
schlüssiges gehört haben wir noch dazu
kommt noch vor schließlich wir begrüßen
ihren kollegen markus söder aus und in
münchen
herr so der erste frage die liegt
einfach auf der hand haben sie
verständnis dafür dass wir jetzt eine
taskforce test logistik ausrufen
unter zuhilfenahme von sechs
bundesministerien und welche expertise
wird andreas scheuer der einbringen
logistikern dass ich schon sehr gut aus
deswegen glaube ich ist das schon okay
aber die frage ist ob das alles
rechtzeitig erfolgt
der fakt ist ja relativ einfach wir
haben tatsächlich in den letzten wochen
große erfolge erzielt wir kamen von ganz
schlechten zahlen zu sehr guten das kann
ich auf russland bayern sagen wir haben
tatsächlich nach der einschätzung
unseres landesamtes für gesundheit bis
zu 1000 leben durch die gesamten
maßnahmen gerettet
so weit so gut schon eine sehr gute
zwischen bilanz stellt sich die frage
wie gehen wir weiter wir haben also eine
schwierige situation die basis für alle
entscheidungen haben bleibt eindeutig
die virologie die wissenschaft die nicht
immer einheitlich ist aber doch eine
relativ klare richtung vorgibt und das
sind überlegen wir es nicht schaffen wir
einerseits die kurz davor sich
fortzusetzen und auf der anderen seite
aber die menschen dabei mitzunehmen zu
um sich gehört auch eine breite
möglichen konsens in der gesellschaft zu
erzielen
und deswegen keine blinde öffnung zu
machen ohne incidents gesteuert ohne
begleitmaßnahmen wir haben in bayern zum
beispiel die strengste masken pflicht
mit sp2 oder mit die strengsten mit der
vfb zwei masken
wir haben übrigens schon eine menge
schnelltest eingekauft wie sie wissen
haben wir immer sehr viel schon getestet
auch jetzt sehr viel schnelltest für
schulen angebot zwei mal die woche so
gar nicht nur einmal wie gestern im
bundestag
wir beschlossen wurde und auch wir
impfen was das zeug hält allerdings in
der tat reicht das impfen noch nicht wir
werden allerdings in den nächsten wochen
davon gehe ich aus die umgekehrte
situation kommen dass der impfstoff
mehrwert dass wir die impro gestik
dramatisch verbessern müssten deswegen
habe ich mich auch so eingesetzt dafür
dass die ärzte impfen können und zwar
nicht nur ein paar sondern breit und
wenn ich das noch sagen darf auch nicht
nur mit dieser starren impf bürokratien
empfehlung der gerade wenn die alten
durchgeimpft sind dann in die breite
hinaus und jeder insel der geimpft
werden und endlich auch die hausärzte
einbeziehen das haben wir wohl verfolgt
bei uns ist hier am tisch melanie amann
die hauptstadt büroleiterin vom spiegel
geschätzte kollegin frau man an den
zahlen hat sich eigentlich im
fünfzehnten zweiten verglichen relativ
wenig verändert die instanzen nicht und
auch die infektionen nicht diese
britische mutation ist noch dazu
gekommen die von diesem zeitpunkt ihre
angewachsen ist also gibt es eigentlich
irgendeinen grund für diese entscheidung
die der gestern getroffen wurde
es gibt nur politische gründe wie er
habe ich schon gesagt hat und auch wenn
frau schwesig versucht jetzt so zu tun
als würden da noch andere faktoren wie
die krankenhaus belastung einbezogen
natürlich ist in erster linie die
inzidenz der entscheidende faktor und
die hat sich ja eher verschlechtert
beziehungsweise stagniert werden jetzt
45 prozent anteil der britischen
mutation ergaben stichproben und das ist
schon ein wahnsinn ich gefährlicher
zustand also es gibt eigentlich aus
pandemischer sicht keinen grund für
diesen plan
es ist ja gut dass überhaupt ein plan
gemacht wurde den hätte man vielleicht
auch schon ein paar monate früher machen
können
die fdp hat ja auch schon einen klaren
gehabt und vorgestellt die grünen haben
planen empfohlen jetzt hat eben auch die
bundesregierung die ministerpräsidenten
einen plan
aber dieser plan ist im prinzip von der
minute seiner geburt war es eine
totgeburt also er ist für die tonne weil
absehbar ist wie in ihrem film gezeigt
wurde dass die zahlen sich nicht
verbessern werden sondern es wird er
darauf hinauslaufen dass diese notbremse
gezogen wird und dass die notbremse der
bundeskanzlerin gezogen wird die dann
erst bei 100 einsätzen soll dann muss
man sofort hendrik streitfragen
epidemiologe biologe an dem uniklinikum
in bonn
der strick hunderter incidents da würden
sie jetzt sagen das kann nicht der
einzige wert sein oder gibt es
irgendeine erklärung dafür dass man
ausgerechnet dann bei einer verdoppelung
der 50 eine notbremse einzieht und im
grunde alles wieder von vorn nein aber
also geben wir merken ja oder fange mal
anders haben für mich ist das schon ein
bisschen dass ich da manchmal mich frage
was im letzten halben jahr passiert ist
im sommer letzten jahres habe ich immer
wieder darauf hingewiesen dass ist eine
pandemie ist ein marathonlauf und kein
lockdown sprinten aber auch dass wir
anfangen müssen mit dem virus zu leben
und ich wurde belächelt dafür
angefeindet für solche sätze aber
mittlerweile merke ich dass das immer
mehr auch diese erkenntnisse in die
politik gelangt die erkenntnis dass
dieses virus eben nicht weggehen das ist
nicht einfach verschwendet das sagt
mittlerweile sogar angela merkel ja aber
dass das besondere daran es wenn man
sich vor augen führt dass das keine
floskel ist sondern ein prinzip der
bekämpfung der pandemie dann merkt man
was wir eigentlich gerade versäumt haben
nämlich inzidenz zahlen schauen da wurde
gerd antes evidenzbasierte statistiker
in deutschland würde das dem zustimmen
dass wir nicht auf die inzidenz sein
gucken dürfen um daran alleine unsere
massnahmen zu beschliessen natürlich
sind die inzidenz zahlen wichtig und das
ist kein entweder-oder wie das manchmal
in der presse dargestellt wird sondern
wir brauchen ein ganz wichtiges und was
frau schwesig wollen auch vom rk
infrarote muss einbezogen werden es muss
die krankenhaus belegung angenommen vor
allem auch von bestimmten alter über 60
zum beispiel hat das
robert-koch-institut vorgeschlagen das
sind wichtige parameter weil wir werden
auch infektionen im herbst und winter
nächsten jahres haben wir werden auch
2022 mit infektionen zu tun haben die
frage ist aber wie gehen wir damit um
wir müssen diese pandemie vom ende her
denken wir müssen die menschen mitnehmen
die jetzt haben mehr deutlichsten
gebeutelt sind davon und die nimmt man
nur mit indem man sie aktiv beteiligen
lässt indem man eben klar macht es ist
ein marathonlauf und ihm den
mitte tools an die hand gibt mitnehmen
sie mitarbeiten und die einen sieht
diese ganze diese eröffnungs strategie
anschauen haben sie denn das gefühl dass
man mit dieser öffnung strategie jetzt
menschen mitnehmen kann
entschuldige wollte grad freien eben
nicht also darum haben wir vom
expertenrat männer wie auch empfohlen
dass man nicht branchenspezifisch öffnet
das ist ja nicht auf da haben wir lange
darüber diskutiert wie eigentlich also
im moment ist es ja so man darf sich
blumen im gartenmarkt angucken aber
nicht im botanischen garten dass das
macht ja keinen sinn das leuchtet ja
kein menschen ein aber die menschen und
die bürger die mitdenken die sollten
doch auch als erstes die möglichkeit
haben ihre bereiche zu öffnen die die
besten hygiene konzepte abend vielleicht
mit abstrich vorher hygieneregeln
bestimmte größen untermarken orchester
oder ein pianist bessere hygiene regeln
haben als der baumarkt um die ecke und
dann sind wir endlich bei christian in
dem parteivorsitzenden der fdp
sie haben noch am mittwoch herr lindner
von einer fata morgana gesprochen weil
sie sorgen bei frau merkel hat sich
eigentlich nur die sprache geändert und
nicht ihre politik sagen sie das heute
nach diesem gipfel immer noch es wird
sich zeigen aber wer hat diese höheren
werte mal eingeführt das ist er entweder
hätten wir auch den die skandal
wahrscheinlich gelöst mit höheren
grenzwerten
ich bleibe dabei sieben krisen es wird
sich zeigen in den nächsten tagen und
wochen ob und wenn ja was sich für die
große zahl der menschen in unserem land
verändert ich bin kein freund von
schuldzuweisungen sondern ich möchte
gerne den blick nach vorne richten und
deshalb ganz konkret mal gemeinsamkeiten
feststellen ich glaube in dieser runde
und auch an der gesellschaft insgesamt
gibt es eine ganz große gemeinsamkeit
nämlich die gefährlichkeit dieses virus
und zu einer mutation nicht zu
unterschätzen
deshalb würde ich übrigens mich selber
auch als vorsichtig bezeichnet
aber wir können eben nicht mal dieses
risiko sehen es gibt auch andere risiken
es gibt soziale risiken weil kinder den
anschluss verlieren gesellschaftliche
risiken bei regeln nicht mehr akzeptiert
werden wirtschaftliche risiken ich
glaube das muss ich nicht länger
ausführen wenn viele tausende menschen
angst um den verlust ihrer existenz
haben und vor dem hintergrund muss eine
risikoabwägung erfolgen nach meinem
eindruck ist die risikoabwägung
innerhalb der bund länder gruppe zu
einseitig und nicht ausgewogen
weil die sozialen gesellschaftlichen
wirtschaftlichen risiken nicht
abgebildet aber es gibt doch jetzt diese
öffnung schritte also ich bin ja nicht
schon in sicht genau aus meiner sicht
nicht
wir tragen alle im alltag dieser
schützenden ffp zwei maske glaube es
richtig ist dass auch auszuweiten wie
der bayerische ministerpräsident das ja
für sein land schon getan hat und andere
gefolgt sind
ich glaube auch dass die bürgerinnen und
bürger vertrauen verdient haben dass die
ganz große mehrheit umsichtig ist und
wir haben doch im handel in der innen
gastronomie beim sport bei körpernahen
dienstleistungen gesehen dass der
hygiene konzepte entwickelt worden sind
in der kultur es kommt ja noch dieter
hallervorden gleich bei ihnen zu wort da
sind auch hygiene konzepte möglich und
da muss öffnung gedacht werden jetzt
kommt der zweite punkt frau schwesig hat
doch völlig recht wenn sie sagt dass die
lage sich verändert hat alleine dadurch
dass die besonders verletzlichen jetzt
geimpft sind wo waren denn die schweren
krankheits fälle wo waren denn die
sterbefälle die wir beklagen müssen bei
denen nicht geimpften insbesondere
betagten hochbetagten menschen die
fallen schon mal raus das bedeutet oder
zumindest das risiko gedämpft das
bedeutet die inzidenz alleine und so
habe ich sie auch verstanden herrscht
regt die sagt er gar nichts mehr aus was
brauchen wir also wir brauchen um die
pandemie vor ort einzuschätzen die
positive quote bei den tests also ich
bin wie viele tests machen wie es die
quote der positiv getesteten wie ist die
inanspruchnahme der intensivmedizin vor
ort sind es betagte menschen oder
jüngere menschen die vor ort infiziert
sind
es ist eine fußballmannschaft wie es
unlängst in bayern
oder ist es ein diffuses
infektionsgeschehen dass die zahlen nach
oben treibt und auf der grundlage kann
man regional entscheiden ob man
schließen oder öffnen kann
und genau diese differenziert hat fehlt
dem stufenplan der rückblende runde
etwas falsch gesehen das war gestern
nicht ausreichen
das war gestern nicht ausreichen und
hielten das aber tatsächlich auch immer
noch mit zu wenigen tests und auch mit
zu wenig ich stopfe ich glaube dass die
ich glaube da bei den impfstoffen kommt
er jetzt eine baldige verbesserung und
vor allem die besonders
verletzlichen sind schon gehe ich weiß
nicht wie viele millionen das bereits
jetzt heute zur stunde sind wir haben
die schützenden nass und ich meine ist
doch völlig klar auch das haben frau
schwesig und herr söder in
bemerkenswerter offenheit gesagt man die
gehören der spd und der csu an die
tragen die bundesregierung und die haben
hier so deutlich die bundesregierung
beim impfen und bei den schnelltests
kritisiert das muss ich ja gar nicht
wiederholen und das stimmt auch wir
brauchen schnelltests und sollten uns in
österreich und dänemark orientieren was
die können können wir auch nur einen
satz zu sagen ich glaube viele leute
warten seit wochen und monaten auf die
impfung und wenn die hören wir haben die
besonders zu schützenden geimpft man
beißen jetzt gerade an die tischkante
und ich kenne persönlich eine handvoll
leute das stimmt nicht was gerade gesagt
wurde
es sind einige geimpft das sei ihm
gegönnt aber es bei weitem nicht so dass
für die über 80-jährigen durchgeben
städten und von dem besonders
gefährdeten sind wir weit davon entfernt
also es ist nicht so dass wir die
besonders zu schützenden jetzt geimpft
hätten und deswegen ist ein bisschen
egal wie das wie es sich entwickelt das
ist nicht richtig
aber da braucht man schon traditionell
einmal kurz vielleicht die zahlen
darstellen wenn du diese gerade hier
prozent geimpft in deutschland und ganz
kurz sagen wie viele menschen in alten-
und pflegeheim wohnen kannst du sagen ja
850000 und was ist mit dem nicht
umstiege heim wohnen wie viele sind 80
jährigen über 80 nicht geimpft sind
du wirst mich nicht überbieten war der
kritik an der bundeswehr im grundriss
team bin ich anderer meinung dass hunde
ist es ist eine 26 eröffnung es ist
jetzt an öffnung mit schutzkonzepte
verantwortbar und ist doch gut wenn du
es anders sieht aber demokratischen
wettbewerb ist doch prima ich glaube die
sozialen wirtschaftlichen und
gesellschaftlichen folgen eines
kompletten lockdown sind jetzt nicht
mehr hinten also und da bleibt dieser
dissenz und wir geben noch mal nach
schwerin zu frau schwesig und fragen uns
okay also jetzt soll in den nächsten
vier wochen noch erprobt werden mit
welchen öffnungs und test strategien wir
uns also diese sicherheit verschaffen
in der hinein oder in die hinein wir
hier aber schon lockern frau schwesig
frage also auch noch mal wann sie auf
sicheren boden empfinden sie sich da
wenn jetzt gelockert wird und wie
sehr glauben sie an pilotprojekte von
ihrem tollen rostocker oberbürgermeister
und aus anderen städten mehr
also ich habe schon immer von anfang an
in der pandemie die auffassung vertreten
dass ihr regional ist für
bundeseinheitliche regeln brauchen die
sich an parameter orientieren müssen wie
zum beispiel die inzidenz sie ist es
nicht mehr alleine aber sie hat eine
wichtige aussage und gleichzeitig aber
regional unterschiedlich vorgehen und um
es auf meinem bundesland zu beziehen wir
haben die stadt rostock die von anfang
an in der partie war noch nicht einmal
risikogebiet die ist eigentlich stabil
unter 35 und haben auf der anderen seite
an der polnischen grenze den landkreis
vorpommern-greifswald der zum beispiel
lange hotspot war weil wir einfach einer
polnischen grenze unser herausforderung
haben trotz zusätzlichen test et cetera
und natürlich ist es richtig dass man
dann einer 200.000 einwohner stadt mehr
ermöglicht bei kita bei schule jetzt
auch zum beispiel beim thema friseure
und jetzt auch einzelhandel und da gibt
es tolle konzepte und die haben wir als
land aufgegriffen und ich kann hier nur
zurückweisen wenn der eindruck von
einigen entsteht die auch für deutsch
gesagt noch nie mit mir darüber
gesprochen haben dass wir jetzt hier nur
politisch handeln und nicht mehr mit
wissenschaftlern
wir sitzen jede woche mit unseren
wissenschaftlern von unseren
universitäten zusammen die beraten uns
bei jedem schritt wir haben unseren
eigenen perspektiv plan entwickelt wir
haben uns damit jetzt in die diskussion
gebracht und ich halte es für richtig
dass wir in der stadt rostock mehr
ermöglichen in diesen bereichen als wird
es zum beispiel in vorpommern rügen tun
so und jetzt ist natürlich die frage
entschuldigung vorpommern greifswald
genau das ist die frage kann man eine
pandemie regional bekämpfen herstellt
kann man mit der erfahrung von heinsberg
oder flensburg kommen wir gleich noch
mal zu hören habe ich sagen es gibt
diese tollen städte die mit diese sind
ja alle toll steht also entschuldigt
bitte eine inzidenz von unter 35 haben
und es gibt die hotspots die so hoch
liegen dass man tatsächlich zu
schutzmaßnahmen greifen muss kann man
eine pandemie regional lösen wie groß
ist die gefahr dass es tatsächlich auch
eine sogwirkung gibt dass die menschen
sich dann in die region bewegen wo sie
schon einkaufen dürfen
wie macht man das
ja also man sieht das eigentlich ja sehr
schön an der karte wie die verteilung
oder der instanzen in deutschland ist da
in bayern und thüringen an der grenze
zur tschechei wo die wirklich extrem
hohe zahlen haben sieht man einfach
deutlich dass das ist eben nicht ein
virus da keine grenzen kennt also und
man sollte eher anders herum denken
sondern hotspot strategien haben die man
sehr hohe inzidenz zahlen besser
eindämmt als dass man regional mehr
ermöglicht wenn man sich ulm und neu-ulm
in bayern und baden württemberg anguckt
zu dort bei meinen waren die blumen
leben geöffnet beim anderen nicht dann
heißt das wir uns natürlich mit über die
landesgrenze und ich glaube wir wollen
da nicht anfangen dann auch innerdeutsch
noch kontrollen aufzubauen das wollen
wir nicht und trotzdem noch mal die
frage herr habe also auch das könnte
natürlich eben eine überlegung sein dass
man solche städte schützt tübingen macht
das jahr mit einer mittelalterlichen
stadtmauer aber jetzt hat nicht jede
stadt wie tübingen eine mauer also
flensburg habe ich gerade schon erwähnt
hohe inzidenz sie leben in flensburg in
die stadt hat tatsächlich echt gelitten
ausgangssperre 21 uhr keiner durfte raus
kontakt nachverfolgung all dieses kann
man mit schlechten gefühl kann man jetzt
sagen wir probieren das mal aus und
lockern bisschen und wenn wir dann
merkten dass wir doch über diese
incidents kommen oder nicht runtergehen
dann hatte von merkel doch wieder recht
und wie man also wieder zu unfällen von
vorne an und so die flensburger
geschichte ist insofern interessant
lehrreich dass es eine stadt für ähnlich
viel rostock die über monate im bunde
das ganze corona ja sehr wenig fälle nur
hatte und die lockdown regeln soweit ich
das überblicken konnte streng befolgt
hat im januar gab es dann ein ereignis
mit der englischen mutation und das hat
dazu geführt dass die lage komplett
gekippt ist die krankenhäuser
vollgelaufen sind ein ereignisse einer
stadt die alle top down maßnahmen
befolgt hat
das sagt mir schon dass wir sehr
vorsichtig sein müssen und so lange die
test kapazitäten nicht da sind und die
impf mengen noch nicht verimpft sind ich
teile das was herr söder gesagt dass
dreht sich jetzt in den nächsten tagen
und wochen um und dann wird sehr viel
impfstoff da sein hoffentlich später
dann auch in die bevölkerung ein
aber so lange muss man die testung zur
voraussetzung für öffnung machen und was
ich nicht verstehe was ich einfach nicht
verstehe und es tut mir leid dass ich
dann frau schwierig und herrn lindner
nicht folgen kann an der stelle ist wie
man bei einer ansteigenden ins bei einer
ansteigenden kurve und bei dem wissen
dass die englische mutation im in der
hälfte der wiehre die virus fälle
ausmacht und der erfahrung aus stetten
in meiner stadt dann sagt ohne testen
öffnen wir das kann gut gehen aber alle
wahrscheinlichkeit spricht dafür dass
wir damit die wir ausbreitung des virus
beschleunigen und dann ist dem nachgeben
des drucks nur für den moment geholfen
und es kann sich in wochen bitterlich
rechnen und dann noch mal sage ich den
punkt dann ist der tag gestern und der
tag heute eine zäsur gewesen weil damit
die politisch verantwortlichen gezeigt
haben dass sie nicht nach der erkenntnis
und der vorsicht handeln sondern im
zweifelsfall nach der unvorsicht und
dass das wird auf dauer dann schwere
kollateralen schieben macht sich zog
herr söder sie sind dran sie haben schon
geahnt sie haben in der pressekonferenz
gestern nacht gesagt sie hätten sich
selber nicht vorstellen können vor zehn
tagen dass sie mit frau merkel zusammen
jetzt dieses konzept vertreten würden
noch einmal die wichtigsten argumente
die zahlen sind nicht besser als am
trennten zweiten die britische mutation
ist dazugekommen und zehn der grössten
hotspots deutschlands entschuldigung von
zehn sind fünf in bayern auf welcher
basis haben sie gestern mit dem kopf
genickt an genau der gleichen stelle ist
mehr denkfehler darin der denkfehler ist
zu sagen wir öffnen bei höhere instanz
das ist absolut falsch
es wird nur dort geöffnet wo die
inzidenz niedrig ist übrigens ist die
inzidenz die entscheidende zahl alle
anderen zahlen die mir genannt
sind weder frühzeitig wirksam weil alle
anderen zahlen später kommen beste
frühindikator ist die inzidenz zweitens
incidents ist die verlässlichste zahl
ist auch eine gesetzlich und
wissenschaftliche legitimierte und vor
allen dingen sie ist auch justiziabel
das heißt wir können mit der instanz am
besten so haben wir es übrigens im
letzten halben jahr sehr erfolgreich
gemacht
in dieser pandemie steuern dort wo die
zahlen niedrig sind nur dort wird
geöffnet wo die zahlen hoch sind wir
überhaupt nichts geöffnet im gegenteil
werden die zahlen schlechter werden
öffnungen zurückgenommen oder wird gar
nichts geöffnet bei uns in den grands
landkreis nicht sie angesprochen haben
dort wo die grenzland reise sehr darf
ich hallo dass wir reden von dem
beschluss er reden von denen von den
beschluss gestern und wir reden darf ich
weiter gut werden von der beschluss
gestern auf dem wir angesprochen haben
und der auch der gegenstand zur debatte
ist und das ist ganz eindeutig so dass
wir gesagt haben
nur dort wo die inzidenz niedrig ist
wird geöffnet wo die nc den service
nicht und wird die effizienz schlechter
wird es sogar wieder zurück gerät das
heißt das ist ein ganz strenges
verfahren erstens zweitens habe ich es
gibt ja die tests wir haben ja eine
situation in deutschland das
beispielsweise bei dem pc ist das rkw
und die meisten bundesländer viele
jedenfalls ein sehr zurückhaltendes
testmanagement haben wir bieten bereits
lange schon vorher kostenlose jedermanns
test jeden tag an
jetzt kommt das ganze beginnt
schnelltests dazu da ist auch die
hoffnung da dass das besser wird
übrigens bei den schnelltest muss man
vor allem ein ist wären nicht nur die
menge sondern muss schaden bei den
sogenannten eigenen tests wie erreiche
ich auch die nachweisbarkeit dass sich
eine verlässliche frage haben kann
darf ich damit frei getestet werden also
sozusagen bestimmte freiheiten genießen
ich glaube dass das konzept das jetzt
auch den weg gebracht ist das ist in der
tat keinen ort und keine zero kowitz
strategie janukowitsch lage zusammen
hier versuchen es ganz runter zu fahren
es ist von der theorie her hat es viel
sympathie wird aber zu folgenden
problemen führen wir auch sehen was ich
auf der anderen seite hätte ich nicht
gefragt sie waren
vorvorgestern gefüllt ein großer
verfechter den gedanken aber frau war in
der ganzen diskussion
doch das ist ein teil der debatte die
sie oder sie stellen die frage und ich
versuchen eine antwort zu geben die nach
meiner auffassung dem entspricht was
meine auffassung ist aber noch nicht
über nacht sondern wir reden darüber ob
sie vor ostern noch ein sehr
vorsichtiger öffner war und waren und
sich jetzt der kanzlerin anschließen und
sagen die zahlen heißen plötzlich 50 und
100 ist doch eine einfache frage
ja und ich gebe ihnen auch meine antwort
und sie stellen die frage und ich gebe
jetzt die antwort die ich nach besten
wissen und gewissen es auch für die
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer ergeben
möchte und die heißt dass wir uns streng
an den instanzen orientieren dass wir an
der stelle aber auch sehen dass wir
neben der wissenschaftlichen
einschätzung die die basis für alles ist
aber auch schauen müssen dass alle
mitmachen
wir leben nicht in china das wir können
nicht einfach nur verordnen und befehlen
sondern das ganze basiert auf einer
hohen legitimation der bevölkerung die
das bislang übrigens hervorragend
mitgemacht hat und dieses ganze system
auch weiterhin tragfähig zu machen ist
es wichtig auch neben einer starren und
sturen entwicklung auch einen atmenden
prozess zu haben und dass wir glaube ich
dass eine anfahrt mit den
sicherheitsmaßnahmen gut zusammen das
war eine andere antwort als sie gerade
gegeben haben und ich bin dankbar dafür
und frage melanie amann wenn wir frauen
man jetzt wieder schließen müssen
dann sind wieder die bürger schon dass
das ist in der tat klingt so ein
bisschen durch in der botschaft von
herrn söder sowie behalten es im auge
sowie merkels kanzleramtschef das ja vor
einem jahr schon gesagt hat vor dem
ersten lockdown werden dieses wochenende
die bevölkerung ganz genau beobachten
wie sie sich verhält und danach machen
wir dann danach treffen unsere
entscheidung und jetzt betont herr söder
die eigenverantwortung des einzelnen und
es schwingt natürlich die botschaft mit
na ja wenn ihr nicht verantwortlich sei
dann können wir auch nichts dafür wenn
es wenn es nicht so gut läuft ich finde
diese botschaft
die höre ich da schon raus und kann man
über die klar nicht nur als liberaler
kann man die positiv sehen es gibt
einfach gewisse dinge die sind schwer
beherrschbar für den menschen also wenn
ich nicht geimpft werde wenn ich nicht
testen kann mich nicht selbst zu hause
testen kann weil es keine tests gibt ist
das schön wenn ich eigenverantwortlich
bin dann bedeutet das dass ich zu hause
bleibe und das kann irgendwie auch nicht
die lösung sein und um vielleicht die
frage zu beantworten die sie an so
dargestellt haben er hat ja im
morgenmagazin neulich wenn ich mich
recht erinnere gesagt er sei ein großer
fan von yoko witt und jetzt erklärt er
so zu sagen warum diese 50er regel in
ordnung ist ich meine das kann man alles
machen aber ich glaube das was die leute
so frustriert und ernüchtert in diesem
corona management ist das eben sich da
eine runde von politikern trifft für
neun stunden da verhandelt am ende einen
plan aufstellt wie man theoretisch so
auch schon hätte vor einem halben jahr
aufstellen können so ein konzept und mit
länder-ministerpräsidenten die die
hoheit haben auch all dies alleine zu
regeln die bräuchten ja theoretisch die
bundeskanzlerin dafür nicht aber man
will sich com bieten man will ein
gemeinsames programm machen dann geht
man raus aus der runde vier leute geben
eine protokollerklärung ab dass sie
unzufrieden sind für ministerpräsidenten
haseloff gibt schon ein interview
während die sitzung noch läuft herr
ramelow geht eine pressekonferenz werden
die sitzung noch läuft also das ist
einfach als regina das ist er herr
kretschmar sagt eigentlich ist das alles
unverantwortlich was wir da heute
beschlossen werden glauben